[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 ce
politiques spéciales municipal 2020
comme chaque mardi 18h45 vous en avez
maintenant l'habitude dans un instant
c'est jean michel fourgous maire sortant
d'elancourt qui brigue un nouveau mandat
et qui sera l'invité de cette édition
tout d'abord nous partons pour la
verrière ou quatre listes se présentent
dans cette commune de seulement des
civils habitant parmi elles celle du
conseiller municipal d'opposition
également conseiller départemental
nicolas dainville là nous l'avons suivi
ce week end pour évoquer les principaux
points de son programme
expliquer le programme présenté les
propositions concrètes c'est l'objectif
de ces rencontres dans les quartiers de
la verrière nicolas d'un vide et son
équipe se présente aux élections
municipales avec trois priorités
l'éducation la sécurité et le cadre de
vie
on porte les valeurs du mérite on a
envie de pousser tous ceux qui ont envie
de s'en sortir on a aussi des valeurs de
justice sociale on n'a pas envie de
laisser tomber ceux qui ont des
difficultés sociales
on a les valeurs je dirais de l'autorité
on a envie de plus de respect de
l'autorité
respect des aînés respect des parents
respect des les éducateurs respect des
règles face aux 16 % de chômage sur la
commune la liste nouvelle dynamique pour
la verrière propose des mesures
directement aux demandeurs d'emploi on a
deux propositions fortes pour l'emploi
c'est du mentorat que des salariés saint
quentinois coach des jeunes vers hyérois
et puis on a envie de créer l'école de
commerce de la verrière pour transmettre
aux jeunes les codes de l'entreprise et
les faire réussir dans le monde
professionnel dans cette liste sans
étiquette des verriers rois et des
verrières oise
engagé politiquement vivant dans
différents quartiers ou issus de la
société civile n'est celui de maman
jeudi à la verrière et je vois des
moments aussi comme moi avec leurs
enfants
nous voulons par exemple au niveau de la
cantine du bio les aliments ou des menus
qui sont vraiment variés de qualité pour
nos enfants parce que c'est l'avenir de
demain évidemment et un haut niveau dès
l'école par exemple nouveau monde et
suivi des aides scolaires dz
après l'école lors du premier et unique
tour des élections municipales de 2014
la lys porté par nicolas dainville avait
recueilli 40 % des voix le taux
d'abstention avait lui atteint les 45 %
premier tour du scrutin le 15 mars c'est
au tour des poids lourds à présent de
rentrer dans la campagne fois lors du
département ainsi à vélizy la présidente
de la région valérie pécresse annonce
qu'elle fera partie de la liste conduite
par le maire sortant pascal thévenot
elle figure en 6e position place
éligible la présidente du mouvement
libre qui s'est éloigné des républicains
expliquent vouloir garder un ancrage
dans le département elle qui a commencé
sa carrière politique en 2002 justement
en tant que député de la circonscription
qui couvre vélizy à ce jour à vélizy se
présente également en tant que tête de
liste didier blanchard avec une
candidature ralliant du centre gauche au
centre droit hughes
or seul un qui présente lui une liste de
gauche et puis yasmine belmadi
anciennement rassemblement national
cette fois ci avec une liste divers
droite autres ténors politiques à
s'engager après à valérie pécresse c'est
gérard larcher le président du sénat a
adressé une lettre aux habitants de
rambouillet l'ancien maire de cette
commune soutient la candidature de
véronique matillon véronique matignon
qui porte la majorité sortante
après le retrait de marc robert pour
raisons de santé et qui fut élue la
première fois en 2008 aux côtés de
gérard larcher
justement voilà pour ces quelques
informations nous passons à l'entretien
de cette édition avec jean michel
fourgous bonsoir soit vous êtes le maire
sortant et d'elancourt présidente
saint-quentin-en-yvelines candidat à un
nouveau mandat votre liste et baptisé
aller elancourt
si vous êtes réélu comment vous
envisagez ce monde à 2020 2026 il
s'agira déjà de poursuivre des projets
qui ont été engagées et des projets
d'envergure piscine intercommunale
commissariat d'agglomération aménagement
de la colline d'elancourt encore
doublement du pont d'avis étaient
quelques-uns des principaux projets ce
sera votre priorité de poursuivre ces
aménagements et égoutter
les élans courtois d'ailleurs comme les
français leur première attente
aujourd'hui c'est la sécurité donc on
peut pas ignorer cela quand quand on
veut être une ville un peu pilotes
je pense que c'est seulement pour ça
aussi qu'on est con on a la
responsabilité de 2,50 à on est beaucoup
dans l'innovation
bon on l'a été dans l'éducation on l'est
toujours
est ce qu'on est sur un grand projet
éducatif qui va monter jusqu'à
l'université paris saclay qui va être la
première université française dans un
grand projet éducatif mais la sécurité
on va effectivement aussi essayer de
devenir un modèle pilote en fait en
france puisque on nous a attribué
certainement bien sûr un peu dans le
cadre des géo faut se le dire
le projet de commissariats du futur et
donc bien sûr avec toutes les meilleures
technologies et des chances est fait
pour aussi les douze communes
donc ça c'est un très beau projet
d'envergure
bien entendu et on a trois ans pour le
réaliser voilà et après vous avez bien
sûr tout ce qui est transport le on va
certainement avoir une des premières
navettes autonome avec madame pécresse
donc la région qui va peut-être partir
de là fait de saint-pierre allait passer
par le haut de l'île de loisirs avec une
piste cyclable un peu élargie et puis
aller jusqu'à la gare de saint-quentin
donc ça c'est vraiment une très forte
attente d'ailleurs ou sinon les grands
projets vous allez avoir livre de
loisirs et la colline elancourt qui vont
bien sûr se rapprocher physiquement
enfin qui vont se rapprocher en termes
bien sûr d'organisation puisque là on va
faire un grand projet un grand projet
sportif nature sport nature loisirs
dans le cas de djo puisque vous le savez
ça fait 40 ans que tout le monde
s'engueule cette colline d'elancourt
fond on a vu un nombre de projets le
projet a été retenu c'est le projet djo
tout le monde le sait est dedans il
inclut bien sûr une donne écologique
aussi très forte que bien sûr qu'on veut
mettre en place donc
donc voilà les transports innovants
on savait qu'on allait piste cyclable
déjà comme assez importante
il encourt qu'on va intensifier donc
éducation éducation si pour tous 1 parce
que au-delà on améliore l'employabilité
numérique de nos de nos adultes aussi
parce que on le sait 80% des emplois de
demain seront liés au numérique donc il
s'agit de tout le monde et les mêmes
elles mêmes et les mêmes accès et
d'ailleurs je dis donc
nous avons une la grande journée
annuelle de l'emploi s'appelle sky
emploi c'est bien sûr dans le vélodrome
qui est quand même le plus beau
vélodrome de france aujourd'hui donc des
belles manifestations aussi pour le
c'est quand même une des premières
attentes aussi de nous de nos élans
cortois c'est l'emploi vous avez
mentionné quelques uns des principes des
priorités pardon sur les projets mme
prochaines années si vous êtes réélu
pour les principaux projets que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure et même plus
généralement aujourd'hui est ce que tous
ces projets peuvent être financés est ce
que les financements sont bien avancés
je vous pose cette question aussi parce
qu'on a vous avez vécu les élus ont vécu
un désengagement de l'état
il a fallu faire face aux baisses de
dotations est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
communes votre commune si vous êtes
réélu va pouvoir réaliser tous ces
aménagements
alors c'est vrai je vais dire ça pour
toutes les équipes municipales de france
pas seulement celle des longs cours il
est évident qu'il faut comprendre qu'un
maire et son équipe aujourd'hui doit
travailler en réseau à partir que de
cette loi 2015 qui renforce les pouvoirs
extérieurs qui transfère le pouvoir
numéro à l'extérieur à l'interco à la
région au département
bien sûr qu'il faut travailler à peu
près des compétences qui sont gérés par
une interprète vous prenez une ville
comme trappe c'est même pire c'est
quasiment les deux tiers des moyens de
trappes sont gérés par l'extérieur
d'ailleurs je conseille au prochain
maire de trappes d'être en harmonie
quand même avec la région le département
et l'agglo parce que c'est vraiment
indispensable
et ça il faut vraiment des mers donc
peut-être plus diplomate plus capable de
jeu de gérer tout le monde
faut arrêter la gauche contre la droite
voilà il faut aujourd'hui la france
c'est autre chose comme le disait le
général de gaulle c'est autre chose que
la gauche est vrai que là il faut
vraiment dépasser ces clivages c'est un
impératif pour bien sûr fait réussir
notre commune nous en tout cas ce côté
c'est ce qu'ont fait l'encours on a une
liste d'union dans lequel on a toutes
les grandes tendances on a tous les
grands leaders que vous citez
régulièrement qui nous soutiennent bon
là on n'a pas de problème là-dessus on a
des peaux bronzées vous l'avez dit femme
ne serait-ce que la piscine bien sûr que
tous ces projets sont financés
aujourd'hui il a fallu du temps il afut
de la concertation il a fallu aux puces
un projet intercommunal
idem le pont de la ville de ça fait 30
ans qu'on se bat sur ce pont c'est
l'intérêt de ya près de cent mille
personnes qui sont concernées donc ça y
est on a donc l'accord des principaux
financeurs idem pour le commissariat
idem pour les jo et vous avez vu la
bagarre qui a eu aussi pour les jo et
chamonix xbox terme ans mais ça fait
partie de dudu de cette mission du maire
il doit gérer une équipe très plausible
manière beaucoup plus qu'auparavant il
doit gérer un réseau de partenaires très
différent de ce qu'ils avaient
auparavant
et puis bien sûr il faut aussi trouver
les moyens parce que porter des projets
comme ça il faut trouver les moyens je
peux vous dire je passe un temps
considérable aller à paris dans les
ministères à l'europe et c'est ce que
soutiennent nos partenaires et donc cela
dit c'est une très belle mission moi
j'aime cette ville parce que parce
qu'elle est innovante parce qu'elle
bouge pas ce que parce que je connais
les gens depuis plus de 20 ans mes
enfants ils sont ils sont nés y ont
grandi je dirais que
givi gg bien sûr mais malheureusement
des enfants aujourd'hui qui sont à paris
comme beaucoup d'entre nous ben oui donc
je me partage quelques faut aussi entre
eux entre ces deux mais bon c'est pas
loin donc voilà c'est un mission
passionnante avec une équipe renouvelée
à près de 40% avec des gens formidables
et les angles encore tués sont des gens
formidables moi j'ai pas de sur votre
mobilité de la commune d'ici à 2026 fin
du prochain mandat quoi ressemblera à
elancourt peut-être en terme d'urbanisme
aussi est-ce qu'il y aura des nouvelles
constructions des quartiers à rénover
j'ai en tête le quartier des quatre
arbres par exemple à quel avenir pour ce
quartier qui aujourd'hui est un peu à
l'abandon les entreprises en sont partis
il ya des attentes autour de ce quartier
alors d'abord on a on a mieux ou le cv
est en cours et dans 50 1 c'est le
deuxième pib par habitant a préparé vous
le savez mais on a la chance dans les
très belles entreprises donc bien sûr
aussi un niveau d'emploi et 2 et 2 et 2
et de moyens qu'un important bon on a
vous avez 50 % du territoire qui est en
espace vert protégé elle encourt donc là
il faut qu'on garde cette règle
d'équilibré c'est la ville à la campagne
et on va protéger ce concept de ville à
la campagne
on y tient aussi le cas d'ailleurs des
12,8 dans les douze villes de saint
quentin vous avez 12 villages donc il
faut garder cet état d'esprit nos
habitants le soit il n'est pas question
de brader ça il faut aussi être attentif
à tout ce qu'il veut diversité
aujourd'hui voilà ce et cce ya un grand
message écologique qui nous est envoyé
par nos administrés on peut discuter de
beaucoup de choses mais voilà c'est une
réalité
hamon quant au projet des quatre arbres
un nom donne il faut choisir
sait on peut pas obtenir le commissariat
24 millions la piscine 24 millions au
passage un hasard fait que la le pont de
la ville de 30 millions voilà les jo
bien sûr que chacun va devoir nous
donner des contributions et puis donc il
faut choisir le on a un projet
effectivement qui est prêt pour les
quatre armées il faut enfouir les lignes
haute tension
à tel point qu'on est obligé de déplacer
de projets de commissariat parce qu'on
veut pas le maître souligné autour sont
vu le niveau technologique de ce
commissariat
bon donc ont pour l'instant on a passé
15 millions il faut se le dire je vais
pas augmenter comme les impôts des élans
courtois comme ça on a on a en a tranché
on a dit on pousse les et les trois gros
dossiers dont on vous a parlé
commissariat pendant la vidéo
et puis le la piscine et on diffère le
projet des quatre hommes
voilà et on met ce commissariat à la
place des tennis comme le tennis il y en
a qui sont obsolètes
on va lire construire juste à côté voilà
voilà un peu le le projet mais mais tout
cela je dois dire aussi une chose c'est
que j'ai vu qu' il y à un indicateur
celle qui s'appelle li dh qui est
l'indicateur de développement humain et
dans le hasard fait c'est que on a vu
leur lit dh est plus dans une ville pour
dire quelle est la qualité de vie à la
dure vous savez qu'ils font mais aussi
les des capteurs de on est en place de
capteurs de qualité de l'air des de
qualité de l'eau voilà donc c'est
vraiment mon nouveau leur lit d âge
c'est un tiers c'est un c'est la santé
donc c'est surtout la longévité
alors le hasard fait que l'insee nous
apprend une information qui montrait que
la longévité c'est quand même après tout
un critère de tête de qualité de vie
mais il faut être prudent quand même
hein on a un très bon on a un très bon
résultat c'est que la moyenne de vie
dans certains pays frick ses 50 ans je
crois que l'europe c'est 70 santé 11 ans
je crois
donc le monde excusez moi le monde moyen
de sound à l'europe ses soucis je crois
que ces 91 d'environ de 80 ans je crois
que la france se doit être 81,2 l'europe
c'est 80 l'europe 6 81 2 la suisse et 83
le japon c'est le meilleur c'est 84 et
on a découvert que l'encours ses 85 ans
ok alors je tiens à dire qu'il faut être
prudent sur ces chiffres bien sûr ce
qu'il ya plein gré mais c'est quand même
un élément
le deuxième critère de l'idée âge c'est
l'idée du gala se terminer c'est
l'occasion d'un des meilleurs systèmes
et le troisième c'est le niveau de vie
est quand même l'islam pour toi ont un
minimum tout je faire mieux je vous
rappelle dur faire mieux pour un maire
c'est attention il ya les impôts mais il
ya aussi la d'être si le type vous dit
rien il fait de la dette c'est l'impôt
de demain donc nous on a diminué par
deux la dette et les tarifs également
les tarifs municipaux
quand vous allez au cinéma elle en
course et 5 euros à peu près à paris
c'est 15 euros et vous avez la même
qualité de son et d'image et de confort
mais voilà il faut jouer il faut bien
sûr en gestion on ait eu beaucoup de
prix ont eu 35 prix vous le savez donc
voilà c'est la femme chez eux c'était ça
fonctionne bien est en cours pour les
prochaines diffusions merci jean michel
fourgous est revenu sur ce plateau je
rappelle que sur elancourt il ya deux
autres listes qui se présentent à celle
de l'union de la gauche menée par
catherine perrotin raufast et celle de
michel rossi investi par la république
en marche
merci encore à vous c'est la fin de ce
set 8 politique on se retrouve mardi
prochain et puis au quotidien dans le
journal poursuivre cette campagne
[Musique]
le